we knew that if if we were to mess up
that it was back to people dying again
we were in very very dark dark place and
we got out of that
I can't think really of another major
peace process that's been brought to a
clear fruition
but this anniversary shouldn't be a
victory lab we need to look forward
[Music]
it's a rather ground Parliament building
for a rather dysfunctional government
sharing power doesn't come easily in a
divided Society but that doesn't
diminish the significance of a historic
compromise 25 years ago it largely
silenced the guns and bombs and utterly
transformed Northern Ireland
[Music]
it's the eve of Good Friday 1998.
politicians are negotiating inside a
choir of protestant and Catholic school
children singing outside
the future's yours and what we can do
today is get a future that gives you a
better chance of having a good life
the hurt you see me in the background
looking where are we to the left of
moving behind you can just see the top
of my hair
25 years later those school children are
adults reunited with the musician who
brought them to storm to reminisce with
us
I remember learning a song very quickly
and being on the bus lots of excitement
doesn't really know what to expect and
then we got there and it was this big
you know loads of crowds and I bet you
know this is intimidating what's this
all about everybody else's reactions
telling me that these are these are
important people and something important
is happening here and
we've got our job to do in the day sing
smile and enjoy the day out and yeah
this I just remember
it's feeling special no one wanted to
leave at all I think because when you
some great thing had happened
uh Sheamus Marlin later said that to
hear the inside of the talks to hear the
children singing it is a defining moment
in a way because this was the future
calling upon them
southern Ireland had endured 30 years of
violence
three and a half thousand lives lost
but iora and Loyalist sea spars had
facilitated peace talks
with the deadline for agreement fast
approaching the British and Irish Prime
Ministers arrived in Belfast for one
final push a day like today I mean it's
not a day for sort of sound bites really
um we can leave those at home but
I feel that I feel the hand of history
on our shoulder were there conversations
you were involved in that you've never
spoken about in in the run-up to the
agreement yeah there was quite a few
very private and difficult conversations
and really part of it was
trying to
make sense of
the opposing narratives of why we had
reached this position and and then
trying to bridge the gap of trust that
there was
between those two opposing narratives
and two opposing factions and in that
the the engagement with the I mean
frankly the people of violence was it
was important
for the first time the British
government was engaging openly with
Irish Republicans the Irish government
holding meetings with loyalists it were
a good few there were there were sacred
and they were sacred there were
you know even very few of my officials
would have known that I had those those
meetings and in fact one of them was in
a venue and I still can't find a venue
and sort of so secret I can't Point
defending myself why does a teacher
disappear from their own delegation to
go and meet with loyalists
um it was great difficulty
much of the grind work had been done by
Mo mullum her no-nonsense approach
rather unconventional for a Northern
Ireland secretary most contribution was
was immense because she was a complete
culture shock and you know I mean for
those of us
who had lived through successive
very conservative looking very
conservative Big C and small C looking
men who who were secretaries of State
for Northern Ireland I mean you know a
lot of them decent vote but you know
they they were archetypal British
politicians and suddenly in steps Mo
um who was
the complete opposite it was that effort
to engage like it's it's so we've all
seen a lot of Secretary of States come
and go and it was hard to see someone
that would come in and
plunk the legs open the table and throw
the hairpiece off and bang the table and
kick doors and it was unusual to say the
least and the world's media descended on
Northern Ireland in anticipation the
deal was on then off then hanging in the
balance the last sort of 24 36 hours
apart from a wee bit of Teddy enough
that had to be done at our end I was it
was waiting for the other Trimble that's
my sort of recollection and I don't say
that in any disparation where he had a a
big challenge
so it wasn't really until his death and
I saw a lot of the the footage of the
bottle within unionism that I I realized
that uh you know he was up against it
nationalist leader Joan Hume had got
Shin Fein to the table David trimble's
task to keep the Ulster unionists there
did he realize the price he would pay
for reaching a compromise in the end
possibly possibly not he knew that it
was a big leap into the dark he was
taking a a step that had never been
taken before
uh but it was one that he felt had had
to be taken he knew that we needed an
and to the conflict that we had had and
this was the best deal that he could
obtain didn't give him everything that
he wanted it didn't give anybody
everything that they wanted but that's
the nature of negotiation and compromise
the deadline passed but in the small
hours of the morning President Clinton
intervened speaking to party leaders by
telephone
it was late afternoon when the
president's Pace Envoy convened a
plenary session with this be Northern
Ireland's Good Friday
I'm pleased to announce
that the two governments
and the political parties of Northern
Ireland have reached agreement
there are so few moments in politics
where you you are in a celebratory mood
so few moments that you remember those
and remember them for all of your life
and this was one of them perhaps
certainly
yeah the most the most joyful moment I
ever had in my time in office
after a 30-year winner of sectarian
violence
Northern Ireland today is the promise of
a springtime of peace
the agreement that has emerged from the
Northern Ireland peace talks
opens the way for the people there to
build a society
based on enduring peace
Justice
and equality
if you're objective of artist Unity can
be pursued politically as you decided on
the basis of the agreement
how can you ever justify the violence
that took place beforehand well let's
not talk about that David now fact has
it happened
over it's finished those who pursued
armed actions from the Republican point
of view felt they had no alternative we
provided an alternative they embraced
that alternative the IRA went away
and I look on the out in the Falls Road
here and the Sun's shining and you know
and and people have gone about their
business I think about it 30 years ago
we were in very very dark dark place in
the 1970s
and we got out of that
and David had a significant role to play
in getting us out of that
High Pride are you of David and his
legacy I am exceedingly Pride yes
prisoners were released early and
terrorists agreed to decommission
weapons Northern Ireland would have its
own power sharing government and would
remain part of the UK until a majority
voted otherwise but that devolved
government has collapsed numerous times
and is currently mothballed over brexit
and its focus on the border how capable
are the political leaders of today of
grasping
the nuances of Northern Ireland and
helping to resolve it
the best thing for political leaders
today
is to remember if they think the piece
has been a good thing it only came about
because of leadership
it only came about because there were
leaders prepared to be unpopular even
with their own Grassroots constituency
all part of it and it only came about
because there were Leaders with the
creativity and the imagination to say
whatever the obstacles we're going to
find their way through and they found it
we were coming from a position where we
knew that if if we were to mess up if we
were to blow the opportunity which we
could have maybe nearly did several
times
that was back to people dying again
you know it was back to to murders and
shootings and and you could imagine and
I often thought about this imagine if it
had went wrong at half five on Good
Friday what would that weekend been like
in the North
no it's in the hands of the people they
go to the polls next month North and
South of the Border they'll vote on this
plan to bring them peace
a lot can change in 25 years but perhaps
what needs to change most is the
agreement Itself by giving a veto to the
largest unionist party and the largest
nationalist party it rendered Middle
Ground votes of less value
so the mechanisms which underpinned Pace
have also been the cause of the
political paralysis
but the children who sang outside the
gates in 1998 still believe the Good
Friday agreement offers most hope for
future Generations
in my house we see everybody as equal
religion and politics are two different
things they don't come together and they
shouldn't come together
um I think that's very important
um and if we don't set a good example
you know then
I think it's something that I definitely
pass on to my boys and my children you
spend a bit of time together and those
barriers come down those stereotypes
change the perspective their perception
changes and you just see each other as
people and kids just want to play
together and sing together and and have
fun and once they they're able to see
they enjoy having fun too it becomes a
wee and not a awesome name
and those prices of Europe are still
echoing at my head after all these years
even one more time
again
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign